this is a production of Cornell
University thank you for inviting me I'm
very excited to be here it's kind of a
complete honor to be invited to your
undergrad especially when under a
despoil right so I want to talk about a
few different projects mainly spanning
much of my work in urban landscapes in
particular a lot of that in New York
City and New Jersey in general but also
I'm going to talk a little bit about
some global work that I've been doing to
understand drivers and patterns of
biodiversity at the globe urban
biodiversity at the global scale and
this picture I think kind of captures a
lot of what I do and what I'm interested
in this is a restored salt marsh in
Secaucus New Jersey and as you see that
where I'm looking towards New York City
with the Empire State Building and you
know there's a variety of landscapes
here and plant communities that are
interesting and provide biodiversity and
ecosystem function to the city and
surrounding landscape so I like to start
this talk with why why urban right why
does why is there been interesting and I
think a lot of you you're here so that I
don't really have to convince you that
urban systems are important and
interesting to study but we are an urban
species right so over 55% of the human
population lives in urban areas urban
suburban areas in the United States is
closer to 80% and in New York I think
it's something like 90 percent so our
experience as as humans is urban is an
urban experience in general so those
numbers are rapidly increasing
and the urban area itself is actually
increasing more and more faster than the
urban population this is so as the urban
area increases our populations increase
we also increase our global connectivity
and how were connected as a global
society and how ecology and organisms
are connected across the world so this
is a travel time so across the
terrestrial landscape this is travel
time to major cities with the lighter
colors being zero one to three hours to
get to a city of 50,000 or more so
that's not even that's a fairly small
City actually and the darker colors
being days so you know you pretty much
have to be in the middle of Tibetan
Plateau or the Amazon or Greenland
that'll take days to get somewhere
otherwise we're highly connected and the
[Music]
these are this is shipping lane density
so we're connected both across the
oceans and across terrestrial surface so
why cities in general but I I find
cities to be fascinating cities across
the globe have similar structure
including high spatial heterogeneity if
the different habitat types so from this
picture of Cape Town you can see that
it's not all the built environment right
cities highly heterogeneous with many
different habitats
there's sorry there's mountains here
there's excuse me first again
so there's natural areas
there's parkland golf courses coastal
habitats so cities have high habitat
heterogeneity but they also have a lot
of similarities right the built
environment is very similar similar
structure similar disturbed types of
habitats and also all cities have some
level of high density of built
structures and pervious services
a ssin of native habitats and there the
epicenters of exotic species invasions
and that makes cities inherently novel
and makes them really their novel
ecosystems so novel being defined by
hobbes as ecosystems containing new
combinations of species arising through
human action and vironment change and
deliberate or accidental introduction of
invasive species and this brings apart
not only new communities ecological
communities but new ecosystem processes
changing nutrient cycling organic matter
dynamics and so on but why why do we
care right so I mentioned that were an
urban species we spend most of our time
in in cities or suburban areas and
there's a lot of concern over the loss
of uniqueness both across cities so if
you go to a city in Brazil major cities
in Brazil or major cities in China or
major cities in Europe and major cities
the US we share a lot of the same
cultivated Hort ornamental species tree
trees right so there's a there's a
concern of the loss of uniqueness or
biological uniqueness that different
areas have and as we're more connected
like showed you in the first slide we
are moving species across and there are
particular species that are more their
pre adapted or or have adapted cities
and so they would be found across the
same cities to I focus primarily on
plant communities which is why I'm
invited to the horticultural section and
the quality of plant communities affects
both ecosystem processes function of
food webs and biodiversity in general
and so I'm this is really what I'm
interested in is understanding the
patterns drivers and function of these
novel habitats so then if we know what's
driving biodiversity and ecosystem
function in these habitats we can apply
that to design planning and management
so I want to start out just by excuse me
just by talking about that cities are
actually very diverse and this has is
still we accept that now but that wasn't
even accepted ten years ago right the
cities actually hold a lot of diversity
and so one of the first studies I did
with a group of other ecologist and
biodiversity scientists across the world
was to collate data from many different
cities across the world on bird data and
plants so the city Flores in city a
vasanas the city floors were only
spontaneous species so not not
cultivated species or species that plant
species that need human intervention to
live in the cities so they could be
non-native species that escaped
cultivation but also includes many of
the native species that are found and
established on taneous populations and
so we have we put together all this data
and first thing you should see right is
that there's a lot of work in Europe and
particularly in Germany because Germany
I like to say the Germans are very
efficient and they've mapped all of
their flora across the whole country so
we know a lot about the floor of Germany
and urban flora in general there are
some big major gaps in our understanding
of Flora's especially birds too that
we've added to this data since this
slide but there's a lot of big gaps and
so we still most of our understanding of
urban biodiversity is focused on the
northern hemisphere so of these cities
we only had 110 cities they actually
support 5% of the world's plant species
and 20% of the world words birds we also
found that they're of course they're
anthropogenic ecosystems with a mix of
natives
but overall as far as species richness
those are the number of in unique
species city's overall retain about 70%
of those species are native plants and
94% are of bird species are native there
are few cosmopolitan species and those I
think are the really really interesting
ones and we also found that cities are
not unique are unique and so there's a
whole lot of concern a bunch of papers
have been written about this that cities
are homogenized that where you have
because of introducing new plants and
new animals and also because of their
characteristics that all cities are the
same so you go to New York you go to
Berlin you go to Beijing and they're all
gonna have the same species but what
we're finding is that cities are
actually sorry cities are actually very
similar they cluster within their
geographic range and so we found this
for birds too
this is a big project in collaboration
with Franklin sort from the lab of oh
but cities are still retaining their
unique Geographic heritage here's New
York which is clustered of course
fortunately not clustered with Berlin
what is cluster within its own within
its geographic region so similar flora
to to Boston Baltimore and so on so what
about I shouldn't sorry about this so
what about those cosmopolitan species
these are the species that we found in
almost all cities so up to 90% of cities
in each biogeographic realm so on on all
continents except for Antarctica right
so in the city they're primarily found
across the world and what do we see here
we could go outside and within a
10-minute walk find all of these species
right so they're ubiquitous species and
I like to talk till my classes that
think about why these species are
successful what are the adaptations that
they have or
are they developing to be successful in
cities and one of the big things is
you'll recognize a lot of these as what
we weeds are weeds right both crop weeds
agricultural weeds but also garden
common garden weeds and then some
invasives like Phragmites here so we
also looked at some metrics of that the
Convention on Biological Diversity has
established as metrics of biodiversity
and we find that cities like I said are
primarily native dominated by native
species at least in terms of species
richness both for plants and birds
except for cities here's where New York
sits except for cities in Australasia
and those are New Zealand and Australian
cities in particular New Zealand's
cities are highly invaded their New
Zealand's flora has doubled since
European colonisation because of
introductions all right all right so
this led us to think about what are the
filters that shape biodiversity so
there's a lot of conceptual models that
think thinking about what shapes
community assembly but we wanted to take
those and apply it to a to urban systems
so of course regional species is
important right the regional climate
land-use and surrounding area is
important to determine the regional uses
for but then there's a series of filters
that determine the urban species pool
and even more so even more filters that
determine what is in the local community
or the habitat and so I have started my
research program in particular to start
to look at these different filters and
and I'm going to give a couple case
studies where we've examined particular
filters
such as urban form species interactions
and then I'm going to talk a little bit
about this human facilitation filter
which is management and our choice of
plant species at the global scale we
found that the best predictors of plants
and native plants were the cities so
we're really interested okay we can look
at these Geographic trends these you
know common we all know that species
latitude is an important determinant of
biological diversity and things like
precipitation and climate drive biomes
and drive species distributions but what
about cities are we seeing that there
are things features of cities that are
more important in determining species in
this case species density or the number
of species per kilometer and what we
found is that for plants in particular
that the intact vegetation within and
surrounding the city as well as the age
of the city are important predictors of
plant species diversity age was a really
interesting finding because we actually
found that older cities have higher but
have higher plant species richness and
we can attribute that to these new
rapidly developing cities there's not as
not a lot of Nasmith natural areas both
in the development patterns set aside in
the development patterns but also that
these older cities have undergone
processes of succession after they were
established the cities species I
apologize yes so native overall this
plant density is all species and this is
native plant density so we're seeing
just native plants so we're seeing
similar trends and what drives native
plants as well as and on natives
so I've also said some of these drivers
what what else at the more
landscape-scale might be driving species
diversity and why we find particular
species where we find them urban form is
really important cities have different
levels of natural areas different types
of green spaces and in buildings and
things like that and so this urban form
really determines species processes in
particular dispersal I'm really
interested in dispersal so one study we
did was we looked at the dispersal and
connectivity of urban river systems and
in terms of connectivity for native
plant species so rivers riparian areas
are often the largest amount of green
space natural green space left in the
city so if you look at pretty much any
aerial photo of a city where you see
large linear corridors are are where you
see these large this even small linear
quarters are riparian areas where those
where the streams haven't been buried or
paved over and so we set up different
plots along different types of urban and
suburban areas and so for example these
plots are along this dark area here is a
natural area versus these are much more
this is more suburban and some of ours
are more in industrial areas and so on
and so we're interested in both the
effect of surrounding land-use type on
dispersal but also the immediate
surrounding and so just to show you what
we found one of the most interesting
results of this study was that yes
urban river systems are acting as
corridors and connectivity for native
plant species and invasive plants which
we assumed invasive plants but they are
important for native plants
but that anthropogenic species are
moving in the system very easily and so
what this is the riverbank this is
species the top species that we dominant
species that we found in the riparian
areas along the riverbank these are the
species that we found in the litters so
what we did was we collected leaf litter
and trash and material at once a month
and then we stratified them for three
month old stratified for three months
and grew up in the greenhouse and we
identified what was moving in the river
and so we're seeing a lot of so a
cerebrum which is a native plant is
moving in the litter and it's on the
riverbank but we see a lot of these
really anthropogenic these are crab
grasses right so they're moving along
the river system the other one I wanted
to point out was pull again I'm cuspid a
time this is a non-native I think the
name has changed but it's a non-native
plant from Japan and this was an
interesting one because we found it all
along both on the riverbank and in the
leaf litter and what we found is that we
also did we also looked at
municipalities and how they're managing
so these river systems crossed I think
about 200 municipalities within and
they're all managing their riverbanks
differently and so we really this this
result right here really shows that if
it places if cities towns are managing
the river and managing invasive species
along the river downstream and nobody's
doing anything upstream it doesn't
matter right these municipalities need
to talk to each other to each other
that's I worked with Karen O'Neil who's
a political social scientists and they
these municipalities do not talk to each
other and so it it's really a futile to
manage downstream for some of these
invasive plants that these these
municipalities are actually managing for
if there's no management upstream
because they're just moving right down
the river system same thing with my
prestigio minium which is
another invasive important invade
invasive plant enforces and riparian
systems moving on to species
interactions species interactions
especially looking at canopies for
species has not been looked at a lot
it's actually pretty poorly studied in
cities and so one of my graduate
students max Piana who actually just
successfully defended recently we set up
an experiment looking at urban forests
and these are natural forests so and
rural forests the urban forests were all
in New York City so he had sites in Van
Cortlandt Park Inwood Hill Park and
Pelham Bay the rural forests were just a
little bit north of cities same geology
as the urban forests so similar soils
and they're all oak hickory dominated
forests and we were interested in this
question so max did a lot of work on
plant canopy tree dynamics and plant
population dynamics really to ask this
question it are our urban forests
resilient so are they
what's regeneration like in these
forests what are the limitations what's
recruitment limitation what are the
different factors that are driving urban
forests are they able to sustain
populations on their own or do we need
active management approaches and then
also where do we need those if we need
active management approaches where do we
need is that the seedling stage is it at
the sapling stage and so is it at the
seed dispersal stage and so one of the
projects he located which was really
fascinating and really shows how species
interactions may change from urban to
rural landscapes is seed predation he
set out seeds of many different species
so a couple different oak species
chicory species as well as Tree of
Heaven Ailanthus altissima and Acer
plátano I'd use the Norway maple and
looked at what are the rates of
removal and this is a proxy for super
nation and what he found over three
years was that urban seed removal really
these curves the seed removal over time
really didn't change they're very
similar across time the red that's the
urban but the whirl seed removal rates
really they varied so we're seeing
sustained high seed removal rates in
urban and we're seeing this high low
high removal rates in rule now the rule
are following mass teen dynamics of the
trees so this mass team dynamics of oak
trees and rodent populations so here was
the year before this in 2015 was amassed
year so rodent populations were really
high and therefore there was high there
was high food resources in 2015 a lot of
acorns and then there was low food reefs
which brought the population really high
and so that's why there's high removal
rates but 2016 was not amassed year
there for the populations of the rodents
so primarily squirrels and chipmunks
crashed and you see low seed removal
rates so we see this typical very common
wrote into acorn mass teen dynamics in
the world but we do not see that in the
urban why there's many we don't know yet
right so we there could be increased
Scranton for abundance because of
supplementary food resources in the city
maybe there's altered grant granel for
community and identity different
different grant of Juarez squirrels vs.
Chipmunks versus other blue jays and
also maybe there's altered ground for
behavior in cities so there is a lot
there is some evidence especially done
with squirrels that their behavior
changes particularly in terms of
responding to humans so the more humans
that are in a park the less scared the
swirls are
vice-versa so where is where all the all
these dynamics happening I'd like to
talk a lot about green urban green
spaces this is where I would argue that
the main ecological processes ecosystem
functions ecosystem services and human
interactions with nature are occurring
and so we've just defined urban green
spaces to include all natural semi
natural and artificial ecological
systems so they range from remnant to
green even to highly engineered green
rubes and I believe this is one of the
roots on West Campus and so they range
across and there's different ecological
processes and it's simply we can also
say that management intensity increases
as you go from these remnant and andor
naturally vegetated sites all the way it
to these green rubes or home gardens and
so on economic input increases but
native species diversity decreases as
you go from the more engineered sites
all the way to these remnants so why
focus on green spaces so I said right
this is where I would argue that
ecological processes the most important
ecological processes are occurring but
they support assemblages of plants and
animals including some new evidence that
green spaces in cities are supporting
rare and endangered species or acting as
refugia for these species they support
environmental functions but also their
input have important very important
social applications are important for
social dynamics including shaping the
character of the city or the
neighborhood providing a sense of place
for inhabitants and people to go to and
providing a range of human health
benefits
so we've asked some questions about both
research questions in management and
also in ecology questions like these are
things we really don't know and we
really need to know because these have
direct applications to planning and
design of cities for for nature and
cities and also for people's human
health and well-being so how large do
urban green spaces need to be how
connected do they need to be we really
know very little about animal and we
know more about animal connectivity in
cities and we know very little about
plant connectivity in cities
how does heterogeneity within and also
across green spaces support or Drive
assemblages and then this this is a
really important question when do green
spaces act as ecological traps or
population sinks for management there's
a lot of I've listed more questions you
can see which way I'm going my research
is going but what are some thresholds
that consider humans right so like I
said these are where humans are
interacting with nature so there are
feedbacks between what what people
perceive and the and how they manage for
you know one thing we really like in our
parks are tall trees and large and long
large areas of lawn right so nothing in
between
but this is this is not great for
biodiversity right so we need we need
more structure more vegetation structure
in these parks but there it's how do we
get people to perceive that as important
and not be scared because there's a lot
of evidence that people with are scared
of crime behind bushes people like you
know burglars hiding behind bushes that
kind of thing so how do we how do we
balance that also what are the best
management practices
it's human risk so Ted would is
incredibly important ecologically but no
one wants a branch to fall on them right
so you know New York City spends a ton
of money on pruning back branches and
dead trees but then they're not
providing that ecological service for
decomposition for for animal habitat and
so on some of these others include gin
general how does social and economic
factors Drive green space management how
do you collage achill communities of
urban green spaces respond to different
management activities so there's some
new research from the Forest Service and
Susana Lerman in particular looking at
lawns and it made the news it was a big
big deal they found that mowing every
two weeks rather than every week mowing
every two weeks to four inches rather
than every week actually maintains a
pollinator and plant diversity in lawns
and it's acceptable to people because
it's short enough and it's not quite
it's every two weeks so so this was a
big deal this is a direct management
application of a direct ecological
application of different management
regimes all right so I wanna I want to
end I want to end I'm not ending yet but
by giving the case study talking about
restoration because we all know it's not
that easy to promote biodiversity in
green spaces especially in urban areas
where they're wildly different wildly
different soils due to different
anthropogenic activities and fill wildly
different uses and parks
and people accepting natural areas so we
were interested in how do we maintain
ecological connections between urban and
natural areas of the city we're also
interested in how do we Maine
Payne how do we adapt to climate change
and in particular this was done in
Jamaica Bay so rising sea levels and
then incorporating civic engagement and
stewardship into restoration projects so
this work was done Jamaica Bay here we
are here's New Brunswick where Rutgers
is and this is Jamaica Bay a little bit
closer up we set up ten sites across in
different parks across the Jamaica Bay
in Brooklyn and Queens and they were
these parks were assessed by the u.s.
Forest Service social scientists as part
of their um use park use in ecological
and assessment social assessment of
parks so we chose we worked with them to
choose different types of parks
different usages for example this park
right up here is a tiny little park that
is dominated by a cricket pitch so it's
primarily used by the cricket league but
there's some edge habitat that we can
use for restoration and incorporate
native biodiversity into these areas one
of these other parks has a strong
neighborhood association that what that
watches over the parks one of these up
here is right near a big mall and it's
just just people just walk through they
don't even look at what what is there
it's a long linear corridor along a
canal and the mall and a road over here
and people just walk through to get to
the mall so then this is a national this
is Gateway National Wildlife Refuge so I
was really interested okay how can we
take these we have tons of lawns right
high stays in particular we have a lot
of lawn area how could we take some of
those lawns to be ecologically or to
support more diversity basically and we
can take little pieces of parks that
aren't being
used but we can also use these not just
to promote ecological diversity and
restoration understand restoration in
cities but also to show people the
community what types of native plants
that can be utilized in their yards and
gardens so we worked with a Amanda
Bailey who was at New York City parks
and landscape architect of New Year's
city parks at the time and we designed
this experiment we call it a designed
experiment after Alex Olsen's work and
design this are different species and
distribution of these different species
so that it would look pretty eventually
when it grew in for people to walk
through and say oh hey I really like New
England aster I'm gonna plant this in my
yard or hey I really like
prunus maritima which is beech plum and
so because we were on the coast we were
we chose species that are that are found
in coastal urban I mean not necessarily
urban but coastal habitats really kind
of picking out a coastal grassland
shrubland habitat and we chose species
that are colorful that provide fruits
and and flowers also for insects and
birds so these are our species you see
we have some really pretty solid aygos
her golden rods
ilex apakah which is American holly has
these nice red berries milkweeds
everybody is really in in to planting
milkweed right now for the Monarchs and
we've planted them and we followed a few
different things in terms of at the site
scale plant population dynamics or these
were plenty news upland from these
species upland from where they're
normally found because we're we're
planning for sea level rise
but we're also planting them in wildly
different soils from more natural soils
these sandy this is what the soil should
look like on this post to these high
organic soils in a swale on the side of
a park and so can we even do this can we
restore can we provide connections and
can we restore in response to climate up
to sea level rise so after a couple
years this is what they look like this
is a site right on the water is
literally right out here but it has the
soil is heavy fill so there's a lot of
mugwort in this site this is a more
natural soil but and so we're seeing a
lot of these our species come in nicely
I also forgot to mention that we had two
treatments two different three four
treatments we weeded some of the plots
we tilled some of the plots to
ameliorate soil compaction and then we
left some of the plots the same and so
we're following over time
we're following growth and reproduction
of different species this is bayberry
mirela Pennsylvania in general not
surprisingly many species are responding
in particular to sand content of the
soil so Morelia does pretty well the
more sand there is it's a beach it's
found on dunes so right behind the
primary dunes on the back of the primary
dunes so it loves sand but some of our
other species did terrible in a sand
even though they are part of the
community of maritime shrublands and
then we also found early results so we
want to follow this over 10-15 years
early results found that actually for
most of the species I'm just showing
bayberry here but that not tilling was
important and actively waiting so really
reducing competition so so not too
so telling turns out it's important
until Marilee soil compaction but it
also allows for the existing seed bank
so it disturbs the soil enough so the
existing seed bank which is mostly full
of mugwort and fresh some Phragmites
although yeah to come up and so the
competition is actually a really
important component of ecological
restoration success in these sites the
other the other component of this
project was to act to look at civic
engagement and so really if we think
about social ecological systems the
ultimate goal is that social resiliency
will lead to ecological resiliency and
so on and so we want to ask what types
of restoration stewardship activities
people would be interested in because
these are smack in the middle of parks
and some of the parks we chose of course
were parks that had that were just
people just went through and didn't pay
attention to and some of the parks had
very strong neighborhood groups that
managed the parks themselves and so we
asked this question what aspects of
individuals environmental knowledge
identity demographics and views of
engagement in their community might
predict willingness to engaged in
restoration stewardship activities and
this project was led by Amanda Sorenson
who's now a postdoc at University of
Nebraska and Gloria Blasi who is a was
the undergraduate records and is now a
graduate student in natural resources
here and she's not here today
unfortunately she's in city working in
the city so we asked a bunch of
questions I had really I was really
interested in this part of it as well as
stewardship capacity what do people
think of these plants so you can find
these at Home Depot so what do people
think of them would they plant them in
their yards we also ask questions about
stewardship capacity so what are their
views and motivations
what do they think of climate change
what is their what is their views on
climate change and adaptation to climate
change and actually it turns out because
this area was heavily hit by Hurricane
sandy that they are very well aware of
the impacts of climate change and
they're very supportive of anything that
could possibly help ameliorate those
effects and so on so they visited parks
on weekend both weekend and weekday
hours during peak summer use and they
randomized sampling so they picked
basically every third person they saw
they interviewed them and what do they
find so one of the these are some of the
questions they found what they found
most importantly was there this this is
what predicts people's willingness to be
involved in restoration activities in
the city and so there the fact if they
found if they said yes that research on
the role or effective native plants is
important they were highly likely to
want to participate if they thought
native plants and animals served an
important role age was important so
older this is found in a lot of these
types of surveys and environmental
stewardship that older older people are
more likely to be involved and say they
want to be involved what was interested
so these are all the other questions
that came out as important predictor of
stewardship preserving local
biodiversity when they volunteer they
want to go outdoors and so on
they found that perceptions of
themselves as an environment wasn't a
strong predictor of stewardship and
gender and education also was not and
race and ethnicity was not an important
predictor of stewardship one of the
really interesting I thought this is
interesting but I'm coming from a pretty
strict ecology side of this
that people were more interested in
taking care of the restoration than
collecting data and the reason that they
weren't as interested in collecting data
was because they were afraid they would
do it wrong that they date that a
scientist was felicity
participating in cleanup events and so
on that was very
they were very likely to want to
participate in that as for perceptions
this I thought was the most fun so they
showed them our they did this the first
year one year after planting so our-our
designed experiments did not look very
nice they weren't grown in so we
couldn't show people the actual sites
the actual restoration sites but we
showed picture they show pictures of the
plants so basically they had people rate
the different species as very attractive
somewhat attractive not attractive at
all
Micra Stadium was is not planted there
but it was added as a distractor item so
one species they hated people hated was
northern Bay berry which is funny
because it's often used in in this
horticulturally but it looked a lot
messier than because you can clip it
back and it looks you know square and it
looks very nice but this picture did not
look like that they love people love New
York aster why this is bayberry this is
New York aster you can see why people
loved it they we asked what they
consider if this was sold at the Home
Depot next to the mall next to the one
park would they buy it yes they would
they would consider using native plants
only a few people said no I'm sure
there's some bias here in terms of
wanting to please the surveyor but
overall this is a pretty pretty good
result and then they as
people just to give what do they like
about the plants shown so of the plants
a light what did they like about them
and so flowers that's a big one so
things like milkweed Beach plum salad a
go they all have nice showy flowers and
people really like them they said they
were pretty and colorful they like the
shape the purple that's New England
aster right right there and what did
they not like sorry they did not like
some of the plants they didn't like
really this stuck out is water and
mosquitoes they thought the plants the
kind of messy shape would and you know
they just looked kind of natural but
messy would attract mosquitoes they
don't but that's another story
somewhere boring because they said they
look like weeds and my personal favorite
was just very New York so what can we
learn from all of this research is this
is very quick and dirty so what can we
learn about design in general and
designing urban habitats from the entire
talk right well design occurs of course
at different scales right and so at the
city wise scale increasing naturally
vegetated green space is really
important we showed that in that global
study where intact vegetation large
amounts of intent or more intact
vegetation which means natural
vegetation led to more species and then
also providing connectivity within the
seed city and surrounding region at the
neighborhood scale I didn't talk about
some of the results other results but
having a local champion is really
important so far in fostering
connections with among residential yards
and other urban green spaces with
community engagement so one of the parks
that we we looked at so some we did have
a course in any urban experiment you
have vandalism one of our sites was
never touched
and that's cuz mr. Rogers who's probably
70 year old african-american man the
first day we were out there he came up
we talked to him he loved our project
and he said don't worry about the
teenagers I'll talk to them no one
touched our site so having a local
champion or a group we also had another
site where we had the Queens Park
Alliance and Friends of Springfield Park
and they made sure that the restoration
sites weren't vandalized
we had another site that was behind a
fence and we lost the site to an illegal
Chop Shop so we kept going back to
sample well first the first time we went
out there to plant there's a
neighborhood right by it they called the
police on us the second time a third
time we got the police called on the
second time too which was fun but then
we go out a year later and the lock on
the fence was a new lock and we couldn't
get in and the park manager couldn't get
in either and it's the kind of a wild
area behind the fence so it's not uh
it's not law and it's not used it's just
a wild park area and it turns out so we
would go in finally got to go in and we
stopped going there because people were
looking at us and they fully set up a
chop shop there so the neighbors called
the police on us but not on this you
know business that was probably a
neighborhood driven somebody in the
neighborhood so community engagement is
important and we know that from the
restoration literature too and it just
makes sense of course that is important
and at the habitat scale I didn't talk a
lot about this but soil
incredibly important you all know that's
right I don't have to tell the
horticulturalists oil is important or
the soil scientists promoting vegetation
structure and design that will then
promote other species and the
charismatic megafauna like the birds
providing native plants that provide
planting native plants or others
cultivars that provide flowers fruit and
other resources for wildlife and of
course invasives you can't get away from
the base of species management if we
didn't pull out all the mugwort from
those sites from those restoration sites
there would be no success at all time
yeah so finally I wanted to just
introduce our bio net and encourage you
to participate you can check out our
website here but we also do a crosstab
walk which is the teaching module and
every ecological Society of America for
the last six years and I'll take any
questions survey with people many folks
out there would not know right right yes
oh I totally agree yeah those pictures
were not the pictures they use those are
mine but still it's you're absolutely
right I mean the sumac that looks like
it could be flowers right from a picture
yeah so I think the important part would
be to follow that up with the actual
restoration sites but we have lost a lot
of them to miscommunication amongst
parks yeah
you would you advocate that in green
spaces yeah absolutely because plant I
was talking about Susanna Luhrmann's
research that law and I didn't talk
about less pest so lawns with less
pesticides and herbicides and all that
all that are they have been shown to be
the most diverse of course for plants
but also in terms of for insects too so
my lawn this probably looks very similar
to yours yeah so I haven't done surveys
or you know people's perceptions of
these but there are some really good
examples through landscape architecture
research and design for this one of them
is to have clearly marked boundaries
between the like for the and the paths
between where people and nature and so
for example in New York the same family
forest is the old-growth forest at
Brooklyn I mean at New York Botanic
Garden they have a very and also wide
wide paths so they have very wide paths
in the forest and they have basically a
low fence but it's pretty low wood so
it's not it doesn't look bad and that's
very popular people aren't afraid to
walk through the woods there because
there's they're separated they feel
comfortable enough but it's also
beautiful so having those hues to care
Joan SR came up with that
phrase the cues to care that it's
actually cared for so people tend to
like that more or having why if you're
if you have a meadow having wide really
wide like five foot wide paths through
the meadow
so people it looks like it's cared for
know what the first summer we had we
actually ended up having pretty um a
drought that summer so we had to water
yeah if we hadn't watered it would up
nothing would have survived yeah as it
was we had a high low survivorship of
milkweeds because of that but I can
never grow milk weeds in any experiment
I don't know why they come up in my yard
without me doing anything but I can't
get them to work experience but yeah we
did water and we're trying to follow
these we have a fuel we have a few left
the cricket pitch put a the cricket club
put a like a big storage unit on top of
our one of our sites we lost the chop
shop there's a couple others but we have
a few that we can still follow through
so you could see through so that makes
yeah oh that's great thank you yeah I
can't remember exactly we did have a lot
yeah we had a lot of
a lot of things cup that were non-native
we only had a few invasives like the
Artemisia and the Phragmites yeah we had
a lot of colonization of these sites
because we opened up soil and we we
talked about this earlier we don't
really need to worry about those things
but they were all very similar so a lot
of those needs I showed is the
cosmopolitan the city slickers those
were a lot of the ones that come up and
these they're wrote are old plants they
come up in these like recently disturbed
environments but they're not they're not
really out competing native plants
they're not they may be changing the
soil but maybe for the better yeah yeah
sure exactly this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu